Matt is on the line in Minneapolis hi
Matt how are you good Dave how are you
thanks for taking the call sure what's
up
I just had a quick question me and my
wife but meetings have been going a lot
better as of late we are currently on
being except one saving up 4,000 and
just last week we got current on all our
bills good yeah so I just had a quick
question about doing like our debt
snowball and with our budgeting so I
asked her on a her input to make her
feel involved in the budget and she said
that she doesn't feel comfortable doing
the envelope system she does doesn't
like she's like the security of having
that money in the house because we are
because we are renting so I'm not really
sure of what to do as far as that aspect
on how to let's make another way of how
to do the budget system without oh the
envelope system renting and klee
increases the chance of money being
stolen from your home no she just
doesn't like the the fact that the money
is laying around like not like not
visibly but just being there mm-hmm
why where's it gonna go right and that's
that's what I explained to her I'm like
crying because what I've learned in the
FPU is you know the psychological
effects of easing - exactly yeah well
there's another psychological effect
here when you run out of money in the
envelope that tells you that you're at
the end of your budget category if you
have something to set off alarm bells
that says you're at the end of your
budget category then you don't know
you're out of money and you just keep
spending and write low on the budget
right so what's your household income
our household income you want the growth
income yes sir
75 to 80 75 to 80 thousand great and
hold are you - I am 32 and she is 30 how
long have you been married we just
celebrated our 3 and 3 year anniversary
on the 28th of November
okay how much debt do you guys have um
roughly 56,000 looks and how long ago
did you start working on this budget um
roughly two months ago
good are you making progress mm-hmm is
she seeing the progress yes he is fast
her she would say we're making progress
this feels better I feel more in control
what would she say she would agree okay
grudgingly oh yeah yeah so she's not
real enthused right see this doesn't
like the math part of it but I think she
was like all these about any of this
right mm-hmm but she's willing to do the
budget and see she sees feels happy when
I I let her give her input and
everything and we come to an agreement
but just with the envelope system I even
mentioned about doing FPU and she
doesn't feel comfortable speaking about
finances with in other people but I said
that you don't have you don't have to do
that you can just listen right that's
exactly right
that was the exact answer yeah okay yeah
I probably would go to Financial Peace
University if I were you guys and just
that you do not have to do the envelope
system to win okay right but one thing
that have two things I would tell you
one is I probably go to Financial Peace
University and she could just sit there
she enough same things just sit there
and I think that's probably needed with
you guys because I really think that
she's just barely involved here she's
just it's a real strain for her to even
do this as much as she's doing it for
you
so I probably would not mess with the
financial with the harm
system until you go to Financial Peace
University if you're not going to go
another idea would be let's don't do the
whole thing on the envelope system I
mean at our house we only do about four
envelopes but let's just do one let's
pick a category I'll give you a good one
to try food people overspend at the
grocery store probably more than any
other category it's an out of control
category if you said let's just try for
one category let's just say okay what
are we gonna spend on food and let's put
that in an envelope and you buy all your
food at the grocery store out of that
envelope and you don't spend more than
it's in that envelope and I think she
can do one envelope but I don't think
this is about she thinks that the
envelope system doesn't work I don't
think this is about that she is
uncomfortable and afraid the money's
gonna get lost or stolen I don't think
it's about any of that I think it's
about that she's not really enthused
about this whole thing so we probably
need to get down under the problem the
envelope system discussion is more of a
symptom in this situation than the
actual problem and that's what I'm think
I'm hearing so good luck with that